hello I'm Melanie Linsky this is I'm
Lauren Ambrose hey I'm Jasmine Savoy
Brown I'm Liv Houston I'm Sophie
Thatcher hi I'm Courtney Eaton I am
Samantha handratty I'm Sophie Nelly
Simone Kessel Tony Cypress we are the
cast of yellow jackets and today we are
taking a BuzzFeed quiz to see which
Yellowjackets character we are it was
brilliant perfect nailed it great
first what quality do you most admire in
a friend honesty sense of humor kindness
loyalty creativity or supportiveness
debating between like
honesty and Sensational sense of humor
is so important I guess maybe more in a
important
I do love a sense of humor but it's not
a maker or breaker is it although when
they're boring honestly honestly just be
honest
well all my friends are very loyal but
they're also super supportive with
bullish women that get done
supportiveness I think kindness
say creativity I don't know
pick your 90s celeb Crush Winona Ryder
duh that was so fast the owner writer is
an option George Clooney Mario Lopez
Freddie Prinze Jr Sarah Michelle Geller
and Halle Berry obviously Winona Ryder
for me it's Winona Ryder my God
Heather's a Winona writer can do no
wrong where's Oliver Platt he's not here
I'm so serious that was my 90s to live
Crush so I don't know what to do with
any of these people Halle Berry no no or
no the picture of Halle Berry is killing
me that hair and about
I don't know honey you're just gorgeous
okay pick a high school class to attend
Taylor Swift and the sociology of Fame a
tree climbing 101 Lego robotics vampires
in cinema the evolution of hip-hop an
intro to crocheting I do love crocheting
crocheting sounds really soothing
I'm gonna do the tree climbing tree
climbing on crochet and really I bought
a ranch in Colorado and I'm getting some
alpaca to make my own freaking yarn so
intro to crochet
not think he would say that well I'm
doing some hip-hop over there are you
okay crocheting me a little leg warmers
oh yeah pick a character to trusts
secret coach Ben Jackie Jeff Cali Walter
Simone well let's actually think about
this because Simone that's my answer I
want to pick coach Ben because I think
that'll lead me to Natalie you little
rat probably coach Bean
I'm gonna say Jeff coach Ben see ya I'm
not good because no actually not Jeff
because just a ding dong I'm gonna go
for Walter because I feel like Walter
will not judge me at all I'm going coach
yeah same imagine being in that cabin
with those girls I I want to chop
something else off Simone all the way
she's my wife and I love it
pick a 90s song to Belt It karaoke Say
My Name by Destiny's Child Wonder well
by Oasis Baby Got Back by Sir Mix-A-Lot
I'm Just a Girl by No Doubt I Want It
That Way by the Backstreet Boys Baby One
More Time by Britney Spears I guess I
would do I want it that way because
everyone was
Almost Say My Name baby I'm gonna do
Wonder Walk
oh this one's hard I'm gonna go with
baby got back okay pick a celeb to guest
star on season three of yellow jackets
Jenna Ortega jokes Jennifer Coolidge
Jack Black Zendaya or Brandon Fraser oh
Jennifer Coolidge doesn't need us ah
she's awesome she's so good right now I
would like to see her dressed in purple
at my cult you know what I love Brendan
Fraser I loved him on the affair Jack
Black I love you I want to be like cool
like cabin guy but I'm also yeah Academy
is freaky I was a really good in Kung Fu
Panda I don't know why because I don't
know him at all but I feel like you
would get off I think we did I think we
would and finally pick something
important from Yellowjackets shawna's
journals the man with no eyes the symbol
the flight recorder the antler queen or
Jackie's Jersey all of these Hammer
cream I mean
whoever the antler Queen is oh my God it
comes up yeah let's go push it right
away I think it's gonna be amazing
cheers
[Laughter]
oh I'm not
I'm not too I missed it
[Applause]
Natalie sorry are you kidding me I
oh my God I do nothing like taisa um
your ambitious intellectual and cunning
like Ty you constantly have your eyes on
the fries and always try to be prepared
for whatever life throws at you that is
so great personality matches with Matt
your headstrong impulsive and total
badass like Nat some people might think
you're a little intimidating at first
that's you
that's only because they haven't taken
the time to really get to know you
you're someone who keeps their feelings
pretty close to their chest but you
would do anything for the people is that
true is that ring true oh my God that's
like very much the definition of who I
am
guess what mine is your personality not
just Misty oh God you're just someone
who knows what they want and will do
anything to get it I mean gosh darn
that's me come on right I mean it's your
character figure out which Yellow
Jackets character you are yeah
yeah and make sure you watch season two
of Yellowjackets on Showtime and
Paramount Plus
[Music]